you were right
we need to decide no no no no let's
appreciate the definition of a globe
[Music]
um i'm 19. i
go to saddleback right now it's
community college by where i live i'm
majoring in real estate development and
then i also do photography and acting
you know what i feel really bad of is
someone this because these are all
people who have glow ups but what
happens if they pop the head around the
camera like so when's the glow-up
happening
oh you thought you got better looking
nah that was a lateral move
like oh
according to who
honestly they're not that bad the
goggles are so funny
do it
go go out and do it
you ladies glow up is not real glow up
okay
y'all using all makeup and [ __ ] like
that i i believe that mango up is a real
book we have nothing
but this okay
okay we grow up on this maybe we're
gonna go to the barber we're gonna get
we're gonna go to the gym y'all got
makeup
this is not a glow-up this is sorcery
okay
most of your glow-ups is sorcery
some of y'all you know some of y'all
some of y'all do manage to whatever
whatever what not do whatever thing in
because you know but most of y'all it
ain't glow ups
it's makeup and makeup ain't a grow up
it's not a glow up i disagree you could
disagree if you want i disagree i don't
see them go from uglies
to and i always say it too you know i
mean ladies who got really attractive
later on in life always got the sweetest
juices yes yeah and it's not i'm talking
but i talk it's not makeup you you're
gonna bypass a whole part of what i say
no because you say muslim not having
real gloves i think just as equally as
men ladies are having just as many
gloves that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that a lot of you the glow-ups is
makeup i'm not saying that there's not
genuine glow-ups
with the women that's not what i'm
saying hey okay maybe i misunderstood
what i'm saying i'm just saying that a
lot of your glue
a lot of your glow ups is makeup and
that's not a real glow up but yeah there
is some glo yeah there's there is some
gloves that is nice i said that all
right you'll always be bypassing a whole
[ __ ] thing
so you guys let us know the awkward
stage of life like they're really not
that bad my little sister does cheer too
so i kind of thought of her she
definitely looked like that at one point
i mean are any yearbook photos really
that good i wish one of these guys would
just come up here and be like oh you got
12. yeah he was kind of bad
that's a no-no you can't say you almost
have to look at these pictures and be
like yeah he was [ __ ] ugly because
i'm not end up on the most wanted list
bruh
i have the fbi knocking for no reason
you can't be looking at no 11 year old
girls and be like he was kind of smashed
no you can't be that nah you can't do
that [ __ ] i'd be like yeah no you ugly
if you think about it because we did the
previous episode with the woman looking
at the that's okay but once you flip it
you realize that's fine this gets a
little weird don't it's fine this whole
premise is weird that's fine a lady
saying that's fun i'm not gonna say it
oh [ __ ] that girl is pretty nah
b can't do that you can't even say a
girl had potential be like yeah she i
could see the traits now she's gonna
grow nah that's off limit don't do it
don't do it
like everything's bad about taking a
yearbook photo so honestly my man got
that [ __ ]
nicholas cage haircut the [ __ ] bird
nest on his head
he doe don't he [ __ ] look like
he got wings i'm gonna go with
contestant
three
i don't really know my reason i just
think number three first
i would i would have kept her
there are no beautiful ginger people
that's that's that's if you're redheaded
and you're watching right now it's okay
that's that's an opinion i like my
gingerbread
hi hi nice to meet you i'm so sorry i
feel so bad nice to meet you what's your
name
hey listen you know what i stand behind
what i should
it would have cost you nothing to not
have said that that's look like she
can't decide between being a hipster or
a vampire diaries person but you know
what it's cool marshall nice to meet you
nice to meet you
glow up for sure thank you she
definitely looked way better than her
initial pictures number seven
[Music]
you think she's gonna be
fired she's gonna be all right she's
gonna be i think she's gonna be all
right i think it's gonna be cool what
you was at 13 what you gonna be today
hi hi nice to meet you so i felt like me
and my mother girl almost my age are
going to be eliminated now all right i
was wrong whatever you're scared she
looked good don't don't pay attention
when i'm wrong don't pay attention don't
worry attention yeah they're not they're
really not that bad well they are
[Laughter]
yours is funny how old were you in that
i guess like 14 ish that's not bad
that's just young okay nice to meet you
nice to meet you too
nice to meet you yeah she got that
ukrainian yi escape the struggle
yeah potatoes
all right not the disney kind of vodka
vodka
vodka potatoes that's crazy but i'm not
cultured enough to know what that means
that means that that's how they make
vodka hey listen whenever i try to
romance a russian chick i'm like so how
do you feel about progress you know
and she's like wrong
yeah that's poland we got something
similar yeah she's being a jet she being
jackass yeah should have just asked
yourself oh you don't eat pierogies how
about ukrainians and then i just see
where that goes
you just [ __ ] switch like that
i'm gonna go with
number
two
[Music]
hi i'm ellie marshall nice nice to meet
you
how are you good glow for sure again
yeah yeah thank you okay you know what
okay you need to have a glue up no no
okay okay okay listen i'm gonna i want
to concede something go ahead
we watched the previous episode then we
watched this one
the men had glow-ups these ladies
i mean
i can see did i not concede
i'm just walking [ __ ] can i take a walk
what are you taking control
let me take a while you concede keeping
seating
so while i concede he proceeds to take a
walk yeah i'm good all right all right
okay
i'm conceited that's not a glow-up
that's a grow up i know women who had a
yes
okay number two was pretty attractive
yeah yeah
number five
hi
marshall nice to meet you
i like your outfit thank you it looks
awesome i mean listen they look better i
guess
than when they were you know teenagers
y'all saw what we saw right
compared to the last episode
this episode i feel
that's tough
that's tough
are you a glow up
maybe the room's too bright can't see
the glow
no no
maybe the room still i'm just saying i i
could see a bit of cell phone like i
don't know
bright as [ __ ] ah
battery
man it's just me
y'all saw what we saw but you know what
i respect women so [ __ ] much as crazy
like
women if you didn't know how much i
respected y'all like
so you know
that's all i just wanted to just let you
guys know how much i [ __ ] respect
y'all anything you want to say yeah i
don't know how you guys got that one but
good job like he looks like elvis it's
like i don't know if it's because like
the the trailer for the new elvis movie
is in my head but he like looks he looks
like elvis not three burgers down the
throat dying on the toilet bowl i love
this but you know i thought she would
say he looks like elvis like he uh
steals black people's music
i'm currently a senior at ucla
nobody cares so let's just say
hold up am i wrong to want to skip this
[ __ ] do any of you [ __ ] want to
hear these women's answers we just want
to see whether they glowed up or not i'm
online up to now
not a lot of people like it though so
yeah
like i can see the potential in my girl
you can see the potential in a 13 year
old yeah i said it
i could see that you know you don't look
good when you're gonna be later
listen right now you look like that
let me finish down let me finish
let me finish you can't cut my answer
so we know you are finished
yo because i mean
yeah not like not right now you look at
that 13 year old but i gotta see like
you can look good later on you're gonna
be all right you're gonna be fine
there's some people you're like
and then they glow up and you're like oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened to you
i just want to say that i really respect
women let's keep playing
unfortunately i'm going to eliminate
jerry
hi
nice to meet you marshall
where did jerry come from we
have to define
hey the definition of a glow hey listen
i'm gonna just say this
i'm gonna just say this preach
you were right
we need to decide no no no no no let's
appreciate the definition of a globe
you were right let's go jesus next
elimination
number
six
i think she gonna look decent she got
slippers hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
janae marshall hey
i could i could smell it but i mean
but no i'm not going to say nothing
because chris hanson but anyways
so real estate that's cool yeah that's
what yeah i uh it's so hard i was like
real estate you know it's the same thing
but that's cool that you're
out from your license um two months away
okay so it's in two months i'm gonna
there you go take my test hopefully i
passed the first time did you pass the
first i did oh yeah it was really nice
yeah yeah
he's what i expected him to look like
right after he said he's into real
estate i was like i had like an image of
what he would definitely somebody i
would have like had a little crush on
back in the day
but now that she had her glow up she's
like
naggers
i'm scared
i was oriented oh jeez
are you excited yes
okay do you feel like you need the right
choice
i think so
[Music]
hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
haley marshall
good to meet you i thought she had a i
thought you had a cool story thank you i
appreciate that you just grew up
i risked my case
my case is rested
go ahead
i mean you know listen
it is what it is if the nigga's right
the knee is right baby
listen i'm not gonna say nothing it's
not a go up
and your glue ups is not really go up if
you got makeup it's not a glue up
i've seen some busted [ __ ] wit
i've seen some busted [ __ ] with
real glow ups no makeup and that was i
was like yes but i've seen makeup on the
busted most busted [ __ ] out
there and i would and i was like oh [ __ ]
this is a different person we don't
necessarily have that
okay